did Shazam Fury of the Gods catch
lightning in a bottle again or is it
just another overblown overstuffed
sequel Twitter's surprising reactions
are pouring in as James Gunn and Peter
saffron prepare to kick off the revamp
to DC Universe leaving the DC extended
Universe largely behind we're witnessing
the final few releases that were green
lit prior to their hiring before we get
to check out fellow holdouts like The
Flash and Aquaman and the lost kingdom
will get to meet up with their Shazam
Lee once again for Shazam Fury of the
Gods this sequel to The 2019 film sees
Shazam and his super-powered family take
on Godly new foes who threaten the
entire world ahead of the release of
Fury of the Gods some critics were
fortunate enough to see the sequel early
going on to post their reviews online so
potential moviegoers know what to expect
from it overall most are in agreement
that it's well just fine it has its big
moments and gives you what you would
want from a Shazam Adventure But
ultimately fails to surpass his
predecessor of course these assessments
come from small group of critics what
does The Wider DC and Shazam fan base
think about this long-awaited
continuation thankfully for those
curious reactions to Shazam Fury of the
Gods from the general public have begun
to pop up on Twitter based on the
earliest reactions it has become even
more clear than it already was the fans
and critics don't always see eye to eye
many folks on a social media platform
have been quick to voice their support
for the sequel one user wrote Shazam
theory of the Gods is a lot of fun I
don't know if it was better than the
first movie but the villains and the
action were definitely a step up they
also enjoyed the film's handful of
surprises and two post-credits scenes
another user rated a sequel at 10 out of
10 and highlighted the comedy as one of
its strongest elements that seemed to be
a common theme with other Twitter users
Charming in with their appreciation for
the movie's comedic side a lot of people
seem to be fans of the new characters
and well-building elements as well okay
I feel like maybe I should be writing
all this down fans are certainly
admitting that Fury of the Gods has its
flaws but they don't outweigh the
positives as one user said it sees
amazing characters sprinkled with a
heavy dose of hearts that makes it all
worthwhile Shazam theory of the Gods is
endearing hilarious entertaining and
epic Helen Mirren stands out as a great
addition to shazam's roster they also
note that it's a crowd pleaser that goes
bigger than the first as our movie and
packs in some big twists at the same
time just because some DC fans aren't in
sync with a critical consensus doesn't
mean all of them are people have also
taken to Twitter to express their
disappointment and Shazam theory of the
Gods for one reason or another one user
Voice or exhaustion with comic book
movies of this style posting what made
Shazam unique was portraying a kid
endowed with powers that is almost
completely abandoned here for yet
another two hours of good capes punching
bad capes other users weren't impressed
either specifically calling out the
films via effect shots as unforgettably
rough meanwhile one fan had multiple
complaints about the sequel ranging from
the pacing to what they consider to be a
total misuse of Helen mirin and Lucy Liu
we end this now
yeah we do at the end of the day reading
Twitter reactions to a movie is no way
to form an opinion on it if you want to
really figure out where you stand on
Shazam if you're of the Gods the best
way to do so is to check it out yourself
[Music]